des soldatsukrainiens qui hissent leur
drapeau ou pose arme à la main dans les
villages où ils viennent d'entrer ce
sont des images partagées par les
soldats eux-mêmes elles tournent en
boucle sur les réseaux sociaux le but
montrer qu'ils sont bien accueillis par
les habitants qui restent
et surtout qu'ils gagnent du terrain
depuis l'annonce du retrait russe les
Ukrainiens progressent en direction
deerson alors que les Russes disent eux
se repliaient de l'autre côté du Nièvre
et force ukrainiennes un piège russe et
avance prudemment comme le dit le
président ukrainien volodimeki
l'ennemi ne fait pas de cadeau il ne
fait pas de geste de bonne volonté nous
nous battons pour tout
et russe c'est le blackout seule ces
images ont filtrées elles sont
présentées comme celles du retrait les
autorités militaires elles restent de
marbre le porte-parole du ministère de
la Défense ne parle pas de retraite mais
de manœuvre de repositionnement cela se
déroule selon les plans strictement
établis
mais la tâche est extrêmement délicate
pour quitter rerson les Russes doivent
traverser sur des barges ce large fleuve
car le principal pont a été endommagé
ces journalistes prorus quittent la
ville ils reconnaissent que c'est une
défaite mais ne savons pas vaincu c'est
dur on est amer s'il y a une volonté de
victoire de riposter rien n'est perdu
j'espère qu'on reviendra
l'enjeu pour les Russes c'est de ne pas
laisser trop de plumes dans cette
retraite alors qu'à l'inverse pour les
Ukrainiens c'est d'essayer de leur
infliger des dégâts maximum la tournure
que prendra le conflit ensuite dépend en
grande partie de cela